tickets for the in-person sin Week
events are available through the end of
January don't miss out on your chance to
join the sin crew and the sin club for
delicious food sinful movie watching and
more the live event is in Nashville this
March check the link in the video
description for all the details
[Music]
scene does not contain an adult swimming
I love a strong cold open but would it
kill the show to just once begin at the
start of an adventure just once I swear
linear storytelling is starting to
become the new non-linear storytelling
and no one wants that I think get it
he's shelling the beach but if he
designed a weapon to shoot seashells
wouldn't the barrel shape need to be
more seashell shaped I guess what I'm
saying is if Sally shoots seashells by
the seashore then she should shoot
seashell-shaped Shooters I'm sure your
Fortress is a salty waste of coral and
clams Disney didn't even attempt to
incorporate any of Mr Nimbus into their
version of neymore also I'm sure I
wasn't the only one who recognized this
guy enough to know that it was a call
back but not enough to remember that
it's supposed to be Rick's arch nemesis
without Googling it of course this
probably means the show is either doing
too many callbacks or not calling back
to things I care about sorry I had to
blow up your bunker close but the
correct answer was sorry I had to blow
up your bunker while you were still
[ __ ] inside it and with barely enough
time to escape child of my child it is I
cookie Magneto Showplace superhero Mad
Libs and disguises it as being clever
this will never stand at least if uh
bocce ball kitty pride has anything to
say about it okay fine it's harder than
it seems but I'm still sitting how easy
it seems I'm sorry do you can kill
things that people agree are cookies and
does that mean you have barely any
powers in England where they call most
of them biscuits sorry just adding my
two cents to the ever-growing examples
of Morty being excellent at TV since
being that therapist who has an abstract
painting of what is clearly a boob on
your wall just so I'll point it out and
then you can analyze my maternal issues
and make me think I'm the one who's just
seeing boobs everywhere that is a
boo-boo piece of so about my mom I'm a
walking Target for a never-ending sea of
angry nerds that think getting in a
fight with me is some kind of I don't
know platform is he is he still looking
over here uh act like you don't know
what he's talking about yeah man about
that book of Boba Fett yeah that was
that was rough is he still looking at us
I am piss Master here to flush the
toilet that is Rick Sanchez that's your
catchphrase you're in trouble now mister
was right there also where's all that
you aren't even coming from he's got
enough of a steady stream to create
upward propulsion of his machine while
still hosing down the house with a
separate Deluge I don't care how much
prostament he's running through that
thing there's no way he's getting that
kind of flow with these two fighting I'm
not sure if I'm supposed to be rooting
for the pants pissing ugly face whiny
guy or pissmaster all these people who
are videoing this I'm gonna say fight
instead of calling the police I'm not
saying filming wouldn't be happening but
I'd like to think of his power to alien
pummeling a subpar parent would be
worthy of calling a higher power before
publishing your pictures
I sexualized you apology we've been
asking for from this show for the last
six seasons comes out of the mouth of a
character named the pissmaster and
a lot of hand clap emojis on white
Twitter's impression of black Twitter
wow it's sticky yeah that means it's
found a pure heart it wants to bond with
wild my orbs do the exact same thing you
guys saw my son-in-law on the news now
he gets a sticky ore but what's the
catch we're not Rubes yeah your power is
well known in our jurisdiction Rick
Sanchez Jerry's bestowed with a Magic
Orb that Rick doesn't qualify for
because of his infamy in the Galaxy but
if they've heard of Rick's exploits
shouldn't they at least have a vague
knowledge of an incompetent human that
is sometimes with him who inspires
Calamity and disappointment just by
leaving his bedroom and realize he's
Unworthy of any orbs too yes it'd be
quicker to just say we hate Jerry but I
think this is more fun the orb is raw
power trust your heart Jerry it will
know what to do all-powerful item that
doesn't have any fixed rules but instead
relies on the power inside you and for
once can we just be told how things work
instead of this hand wavy emotional BS
cliche this orb is emitting a constant
high frequency tone that is not only
making me hate its very existence but is
a disqualifying feature from being
something anyone would want around on
them for any amount of time like Jerry
here's your goddamn suit I hardwired the
orbs infinite energy right into it
giving Jerry this much power even if it
is to prove a point to a piece of
teenager this shitty thing looks cool
that shooty thing is a nuclear disruptor
that can blow up planets okay I get
making the suit to shut everyone up and
let Jerry have his time in the superhero
Spotlight but arming the suit with a
[ __ ] arm mounted Planet Killer was
100 your choice Rick Jerry would have
been content if the thing had a built-in
TV remote soda hat and fidget spinner
space Hitlers are convening on zeplar
Prime that's a problem tackling space
Hitlers when we haven't dealt with all
of our Earth Hitlers
be the same bad guys I don't deny that
the Galaxy's most evil entities would
take up the mantle of space Hitler but I
do find it hard to believe their
conference for all things evil would be
so easy to find and destroy by operation
Valk Jerry over here and there were no
other people on the planet are you sure
because that looks like quite an
infrastructure for just a handful of
Hitlers who are their assistants where
did they eat who ran the internet so
that they could leave comments on
YouTube videos you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me you mean the fact that we
haven't seen the Smith family for
setting up the couch in the dead center
of the room and obstructing possible
traffic flow I know right or maybe we
have you know what we've literally sent
every episode of this show so I don't
even know anymore I don't know that it's
a sin but I just I just want to know
more about the booby doodle okay it
raises many questions both about this
therapist and the writers who put it
there that we just never get answered
release the boodle cut why is toast the
bad guy on breakfast Planet Forks
literally slice your egg faces open and
let your yolki innards pour out and
you're hanging them on buildings like
Reese at Christmas you dicks Council
said I could pick my own Bridge crew
having free reign on your Bridge crew
and not even stopping to consider
Patrick Stewart for a single solitary
second Oh Me Oh My can it be a giant
piece of [ __ ] I see creating a baddie
takes effort and time so sometimes you
settle for a legume that can rhyme of
course sinning such things can be
equally taxing but alas is my job not
this poetical waxing
meme chasing whatever food this is Rick
will now walk in on a dead piss Master
who's taken his own life because this
show has handled tough subject matter so
well in the past why wouldn't they try
it again Dad Mom told me you weren't
responding to her calls and this will be
the Turning Point leading Rick into the
pissmaster rehabilitation project is the
show Trojan horsing a rick
Rehabilitation project into an episode
about a piss Master Rehabilitation
project it doesn't matter I'm not buying
either I know I said terrible things
about you and my podcast obnoxious
Millennials skip I'm okay we're good
this barely putting any effort into a
disguise works for the rest of the
episode
out of guilt for being tangentially
responsible for pissmaster suicide
pistol Rick decides to create his own
piss Master suit and send him out in a
blaze of glory instead of going back in
time and convincing Jerry's mother that
going on a date with Jerry's father is
in no one's best interest oh don't act
like he's above doing that and just
acquiring a Morty from a different
Universe thinking there's more to this
world than news entertainment Life and
video now I'm gonna make a giant bomb
planted in a city and then have the suit
autopilot the bomb into space boom
everyone will think Master sacrificed
himself as powerful as the Arts of
theatricality and deception are to the
uninitiated it's still a bad idea to
model your convoluted plans on
disappointing comic book movie climaxes
I'm tempted to second guess a lot of
that but I think you might be nailing it
wait what the man just told you he's
going to plant a bomb and hope the suit
can save the day and your response is
therapy FTW but he's piss Master people
change Jerry thinking that because it's
possible for people to change then it
means we're required to let them back
into our lives I can't stress enough I'm
eight years old I have no idea what I'm
doing and yet you somehow have a
perfectly fitted explosive Ordnance
disposal suit in some sort of Orphan
infrastructure established look I know
the show's aware of this but setting up
your own jokes like this is asking me to
suspend my disbelief as if it were a
small family of elephants dangling 5000
feet in the air from nothing more than a
particularly overused elastic band and a
crossed finger also does orphan Island
not realize you can be orphaned at all
sorts of Ages in not just as children in
fact more elderly people are orphans
than kids chew on that the internet you
were piss Master the whole time
obviously not Jerry I put the suit on
once pissmaster killed Rick well now
very obviously backpedal and claim that
he was pissmaster the whole time and
everyone will buy it despite it being
utter [ __ ] and not making any of the
sense I guess they just really trust
Rick and or they know they're only two
minutes left and we need to wrap this
[ __ ] up why would Rick even prop me up
like Jesus Cherry Rick did something
nice for once okay he's obviously trying
to change you mean obviously the show is
trying some sort of redemption story arc
that has never worked in the past and
isn't working now the Man discards
People in Worlds like toilet paper uses
them to clean up his own and then
casually eliminates them I bet he
doesn't even look at them before he
flushes what that's what people do how
are you supposed to know if you're clean
if you don't wait Moody you have to
promise not to tell anyone but your dad
made pissmaster kill himself ah what the
hell he killed himself kids wait you
kept the suicide note Morty would be
excellent at what the [ __ ] is this
episode even trying to tell us about
Rick's psychosis since I have a pitch
we're not going to add Scarlett
Johansson not adding Scarlett Johansson
I can't stop going once I started stinks
I can't hold them off Rick there's too
many game over man this game over
happy you're only supposed to blow the
bloody doors off it is a cookie Magneto
go [ __ ] yourself if you fight this guy
I'm either an [ __ ] for not helping or
an [ __ ] for helping what do you say
we cut the Chit Chat a-hole
pictures like Oh Me Oh My can it be a
giant piece of [ __ ] I see
[Music]
who are you I'm Batman well Thor's
taking on a squadron down on Sixth
and he didn't invite me orphan Island a
city populated entirely by orphans now
sits on the brink of Doom
I found him dead and I put on his suit
but look at this he literally blames
your dad
the plot Pickens didn't even know you
had a plot